it's akin to how do we be more authentic
you know
um and and the way so many companies
tackle that
is they go and do market research right
we go and do focus groups
uh to find out how we can differentiate
ourselves
which i think is funny which is the
which is the same thing as asking your
friends sort of
how should i talk to you and how should
i dress so that you'll like me more
and your friends are going to look and
be like what you're like how do you want
me to talk to you and how do you want me
to dress so that you'll like me more
because i care and your friends will be
like i don't know just be yourself
right and this is what companies do they
go get outside advice
to how to be themselves how they should
how they should present themselves to
the outside world
the way you differentiate yourself is
you is you are yourself it sounds silly
but it's true which is you know what
your vision is and your causes you know
what you stand for
you know what your your your culture is
which means you know what your values
are just like a person
right and you work hard imperfectly
because like a person we're imperfect
and messy
and you work hard to do things that
represent what you stand for and operate
in a way that represent your values
and what starts to happen is you start
to stand out
because you're consistent and people
start to be able to say
i know what you stand for and you start
to become predictable
and you're either very attractive to
some people who believe what you believe
or you people don't like you because
they don't believe what you believe
both of those things are good and then
there's always people in the middle who
just
want to do business with you because the
transaction is good and the
the you know the price happens to be
right the product happens to meet a
certain
spec certain specs i'll do business with
you but it's
it's the ones who believe what you
believe it's the loyal ones
that make it that make a company stand
out um and do more to spread the good
word of your organization than you could
ever do with advertising
and so it the irony is is live true to
your values
make decisions consistent with what you
stand for which is seen by employees as
well as customers by the way
people who believe what you believe want
to work there and want to be loyal to
the company
because working here says something
about who i am
um you know if i say i work for apple
you actually know something about me
even though you know nothing about me
just because apple is good
and by the way there's no difference
between a customer and an employee it's
just a behavioral difference they either
work for you or or i buy from you but
ultimately
i believe what you believe the behavior
may be different
um so i think that the best thing a
company can do to
stand out is is to is to stand for
something and live by its own values